Based on what you've seen so far, let's see if you can shift a circle. So here
this orange circle was our original circle we saw with a radius of 50 units.
This blue circle was our same circle shifted 20 units to the right. And keep in
mind even though we went 20 units to the right, we see a subtraction of 20 in
the equation I feel like this goes against my intuition. Usually when I think
about moving to the right, in the x direction, I think about adding or positive
20. But in our equation it's actually a negative 20. You always want to keep
this in mind when shifting a circle. What's in the equation will be the
opposite of the direction we move. So if we have negative 20 in an equation, we
really move our circle 209 units to the right. So, knowing this, what do you
think would be the equation of a circle with center at negative 10, 2 and a
radius of 50? Enter that equation here.